[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name's James LeNoble I'm a
producer in the computer games industry
and I'm here with Viceroy games today
Timoshenko I may audio QA engineer my
name is Scott
I'm Luke what I went for milkita studios
and I'm a 3d environment
okay
and shopping wealth inequality
which is about the time of the game of
winter
a kind of which they came straight out
of uni
jump straight into it and really cool
things like three get three is today yes
always like the pretty much like three
especially it might be
[Music]
and obviously inspired by a magical
beyond belief
it's very interesting game
sexual
so that's like a massive inspiration
obviously as well as of what's motive so
actually I was doing streaming before I
got a job and somebody mentioned the
jumbo
[Music]
and I didn't even know that it just
it was always programming
[Music]
[Music]
so I got quite fortunate and when I was
18 I was working in a pub and I met a
guy who was a Jusuf Bizarre Creations
and he came in said you want to do some
play test and over the summer for a
couple of months and then that was my
into the games industry was playtest in
Project Gotham Racing for and the club
and I just played that and we set the
difficulty levels based on my lap times
and results and stuff like that and
that's how I got in a lot of it was my
job see I was doing a revoke your age
they basically do a lot of my ultimate
stress testing a surfing
there's a lot of life working on early
bills yeah so that was just doing you
from and I think I was just doodling
stuff at one point it kind of came up so
it might have been like that so I
applied for details and based in Canada
so it was always like firings there were
quite a few work was like hey we have
like three years yeah and it did help
definitely it was that little extra
status to kind of rely on not just
someone which are unique experience what
are you doing that why you argue no
exciting that just asteroid I just kind
of sat in my room after uni like doing
nothing like sex at all and every one of
my life that get it done so then I kind
of like to reply for those
[Music]
students like my
I study the ITM multimedia which was
I'm actually up against not much and I
only
I was just going through
[Music]
imagine
the one thing I personally think is most
important is having a solid portfolio if
you've gone to university to build up
that portfolio or you've worked on your
own at home to build up that portfolio
and I think the end product having a
portfolio whether it's design arts or
and like a portfolio having Nance the
most important thing in my opinion I did
music and sound technology I did my
dissertation on mic game sound but we
didn't have any like direct modules on
it so it was very much better I got back
yeah yeah haven't liked the drive and
the kind of the right attitude yeah you
don't agree doesn't think it doesn't
guarantee like it helps and to show the
focus and stuff
we've got programmers who don't have
degrees and things we've got we're going
to your doctors so it's if you want to
get into games
you know you just got to show that
you're passionate about it and be eager
always be learning like always like if
you don't understand saying ask someone
you'll find most people who work in the
games industry more than willing to like
pass on knowledge and help people you
know we're a friendly bunch of skating
deaths so yeah just sort of just be
passionate about it if it's what you
want go for it and there are multiple
routes and you've just got to find yours
I mean that's very hard because I'm not
very social person either
we have to do there's so many different
jobs
[Music]
without you from
there's so many by social skills
they're soldiers coming tomorrow
like steaming for example
community management
[Music]
the community
[Music]
everyone takes her own path there are
multiple ways in the games industry art
I will admit I was lucky to have met a
guy who offered me a play testing gig
but once I was in I was eager and I was
always learning always asking for people
to explain something to me and just
learning on the job
yeah just wanted to learn and not want
him to leave the games industry I
actually didn't get the job originally I
interviewed for it and it was on the
other team Messier and I know now that
it was essentially like 51 so I didn't
get that one
and I was super guy the interview done
really well my talk really good coming
out of it about two weeks later I got
another email yeah because they because
they needed someone on the other one so
it was really kind of yeah exactly it
was it was this rollercoaster of
emotions but the fact that I'd each did
well and knew what I was talking about
enough was really good because it meant
when all those people need someone to do
this did you have anyone else you'd
interviewed that you'd recommend they
could just go straight to me it's great
we have skills
directly connect
[Music]
is put something that you don't similar
to a
because
[Music]
which I'm forgetting the jungle
[Music]
like having
you've really gotta be on it like it
needs to always be in trouble you need
to be paying in like 100 percent do it
because if you find out like yeah
passing out that it just you just gonna
make life not occur self long run
because you're either you gotta admit
like you know if you if you're sending
out loads of applications and things
like Taylor you'll see the rather than
just copy pasting things because you'll
make a mistake
I definitely look back and think like
maybe if I'd spent less time thank you
but yeah exactly like you need a break
can you ever try yeah exactly
easy time well don't sort of flap around
too much but you need to get separate
Chagas puff is a PR game which provides
no controller
it already requires have movement so
it's basically almost anybody can play
you can find on Steam the optimist or
five Lords
PlayStation VR on the playstation
hyperbole tournaments are game I don't
we take it's kind of a sports bra panda
gave to be to PvP
and it's really fun it's really cool
and it's gonna be our alien industry
around March time Steve and that it will
be on switch
games of persistence was developed at
Viceroy games most livable city center
you can find us Viceroy calm and we're
on Twitter at fire sprite I think it is
it's like South by sprite games
yeah thank you very much very much so
we're showing off freaking them start
spring next year putting on team so I do
poster occasionally but it's mainly
pictures
Haggar us who might see this ginger
guard and be like oh where can I see
more of him
[Music]